Hi,
my boo!
What is up, YouTube?
Hello!
Hello, hello!
Welcome in, welcome in, welcome in, welcome in, happy
weekend!
Or hopefully if you're watching, well, I mean, maybe if
you're watching this later, it's not the weekend for you but
oh howdy two years Jordan thank you thank you thank you
everyone the weekend it's the weekend the weekend yeah yeah
hello to the VOD watchers howdy howdy howdy hello hello
hello I was going to play a different game today.
And then I said, I really want to keep melting things in
Meltopia.
I enjoyed my previous melting time.
And I thought, you know what?
Yeah, it is pretty addicting.
Also, later on, I will be having a meet and greet I'll be
having a meet and greet at smash Australia baby we're not
smashing Australia wait but we're not we're not like we're
not like Godzilla stepping on Australia with our giant feet
you know we are we are no other meanings of the smash the
monster smash we are we are it's no no i am it's a
convention it's a convention it's a convention so i have a
meet and greet and then i have a concert um very late
tonight so i kind of needed a game that i could stop at any
time and be like okay time for me to go go eat and get ready
for a meet and and concert.
Looking forward to an ice chill street.
Wow, so many, so many bamboos.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, everybody.
Welcome back.
I know yesterday I also had meet and greet and a panel at
the convention too.
And it was very fun, but my sleep schedule, I go to sleep
around, well, around like 10, 11 at least I try to most
nights but like 10, 11 p.m.
but the concert was no sorry the panel was at midnight my
time giant Kaiju Minto don't threaten them with a good time
okay so that's a good schedule mine's been bad well just
just fix it
I'm 11 months short that's okay thank you so much for for
staying at all I think that was extra cute today oh today
extra cute today is extra cute sorry tax at the pub and
we'll have to listen to you on background only that's okay I
know the games are happening.
I know, I know.
But not everyone's interested in watching the World Cup.
So I figure if you're not interested, maybe you want to
watch me melt some ice.
Isn't it more fun to watch ice melting?
Woohoo!
Next we should do paint drying.
Oh yeah!
It's going to smash Australia.
No!
Australia, you're lucky.
It's going to smash you on free Supa Saturday.
Now, where did that come from?
Who started a free Supa Saturday?
Breaking news.
Hitvtuber idol group density.exe has been steppy, steppy on
Australia with their big sticky feet.
Uh, sounds like somebody's projecting.
Stinky feet where?
Definitely not here.
Thank you for giving a like to my cosplay vehement- Thank
you for cosplaying me!
Thank you!
Grass growing watch along.
Okay.
Don't threaten me with a good time now.
Melting drying is like she knows her hobbies.
What are your hobbies?
Free?
Not free.
Minto cuter than yesterday but not as cute as tomorrow.
Weeks of fun.
But it must come sometime cute today.
Silly thing is we would totally watch a paint drying
simulation.
I feel like there has to be a game like that, no?
Right?
There has to be like some meme game that's like come watch
the paint dry.
It's weeks of fun, weeks of fun.
There is, right?
There has to.
Yeah, there is.
For sure.
Game may be generous.
That's so true.
Sorry.
the greatest game of the year ever.
Committing a full paw by watching Minto melt ice and also
allegedly playing a complex D&D at the same time.
I'm not paying attention to D&D.
Should we load up my game?
We can keep yapping while I melt things.
There is its 99 cents on Steam.
No kidding.
We're back!
Hello!
Hello, Timothy.
Hello, Timothy the Trader.
We've got $241 to our name.
This ghost melts our hearts.
Yap streams are the best streams.
Well, that's also what we're doing here and all.
I'm able to melt things and yap at the same time.
It's pretty sick.
Right, Trader?
Let's take a look at some stuff.
stuff.
Our Tesla would probably need to upgrade.
Inventory has been good.
Warmth is okay right now.
We might want to do fuel.
And Tesla.
We might want to focus on our tools.
Perhaps.
But we found last time the second stop.
And that led to like an ice castle.
Okay.
this place, which is pretty crazy.
So it says we can go down here now?
What does it mean by that?
And then Q is...
Okay, so we can get back up here.
Whee!
Oh, what's that up there?
Oh, whoops.
Q?
Oh, maybe I need to get closer.
Did I need to get closer?
It's just...
It's just gusting out.
Whoa!
Okay.
We're actual Spider-Man this time.
What happens if I go down there, though?
Okay, we need to not dilly-dally, I think.
It's quite breezy in here.
Oh!
I hear, I hear, I hear.
My treasure chest.
Give me the money.
Oh, nice.
How much money did I get?
Holy!
We got 2,000 bucks!
Our heat is going down much slower now, which is awesome.
It's not standing there.
All right, I'm gonna head back.
Ice is the only thing that mint is melting this stream.
I'm also melting.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
Are we trapped?
Can I reach that?
I guess not.
Okay.
Uh, we're fine.
Everything's okay.
Don't worry about it.
We're not fine.
We might actually be in trouble.
Oh, shoot.
We're fine.
We're warped.
I got 22 items.
Can't go in there yet.
So we do have to go through here.
What else was over here?
How are you guys this weekend so far?
Is that anything nice?
um for me i slept in oopsie because it was a late night for
me and then i took a nap i've done nothing i've done what
that's not true i was working on a project and getting
really frustrated because things were not working as i
wanted them to do i'm at an amusement park i'm so jealous
Where's that?
It's double cold?
Who's being breezy down here?
Best part of my weekend so far is being dope.
Stop it!
Trying not to melt.
Ironically, it's hot here.
But doesn't this game make you feel so cold?
It makes me feel pretty cold.
I'm like, oh, it's so...
Oh, my fuel is critical.
That's okay.
Keep collecting items.
Yes, yes.
Oh, man, we were so close.
Watching this with the AC blasting, that's what I'm talking
about.
That's what I'm talking about.
I managed to trap, trap, trap, trap a stray tuxedo cat.
And he's currently in my bathroom.
I'm going to get him checked.
I had a vet for a chip on Monday, but if he doesn't have
one, I will have a new cat.
I want a cat.
Wait, I went to the wrong place.
Made a chicken tiki, tiki masala.
I love a tiki masala.
Delicious.
I want a cat, man.
I think I'm going to start looking at it.
Well, okay.
Part of me is like, I'm going to be doing some traveling.
I'm going to be doing some traveling.
So I shouldn't get a cat right now.
But part of me is also like, I'm so sad.
my cat.
I miss my cat.
My cats.
I miss them.
So, I don't know.
I will be patient.
Just like I'm going to be patient for this Tesla upgrade.
Yeah, I've been feeling not so good because of it.
I'm not going to lie.
We've been calling him Night Manager Panini.
Because he only came around at night.
He works at a 7-Eleven.
is tired of fixing the slurpee machines what is this
backstory why did you give your cat such a sad backstory why
couldn't they come with you um basically my older cat so i i
had two cats my older cat um i was he's has like you know a
vet and everything that like is very used to him because I
would take him to the vet quite often.
They know everything about him.
And he's very old and does not adapt well to change.
And I just thought that maybe he wouldn't...
He wouldn't adapt very well here.
Originally, I was going to take one of my cats.
But then they became like best as buds.
And so...
you know I ended in the end left both of them I don't really
want to talk about it though because it makes me so sad but
I mean I found recently a crazy awesome bowl slop restaurant
by me and I love I love Slop.
Does anyone else team Bull Slop?
Because that stuff, it hits every time.
I love, does anyone else love Bull Slop?
As much as I do.
What is Bull Slop?
It's like when you throw a bunch of things into a bowl, like
a salad-ish, or like a taco bowl, or, you know, things like
that.
Oh, and you can, like, customize it and put whatever you
want in there, and it's awesome!
Bowl Slop is my specialty.
Yeah, like a burrito bowl!
So, like, a poke bowl.
I think so.
I think that would count as bowl slop, because it's like...
It's like... I think it's...
It's all customizable things.
I'm pretty partial on bowl slop.
I just love...
able to make my own thing the way I like it.
Oh no, I forgot the energy.
My bud.
You know what I mean though?
Where it's like, does this one have a... It doesn't.
Dang it.
Oh, I went to the wrong place again.
Sorry, my bad.
I... Wait.
Okay, there is no recharge here.
So I just love me a good bowl slab.
I'm a big fan.
And I found an amazing place by me so I'm I'm if I weren't
dead I'd be living
I wonder if maybe I should upgrade my heat my warmth after
all without warmth you can't do anything you know I think
warmth might be the way to go because then you warmth and if
you need to refill you can buy fill it like you can buy gas
cans for that there's so many combinations you can make and
you don't get bored yeah bowl slop is great you know I call
it bowl slop but it's like out of pure love I'm like yeah
give me the slop give me the slop yeah i'm like a little i'm
like i'm like uh you know when they strap oats to the to the
mouth of a horse that's me and my bowl i'm like yeah give me
that bowl slap rip my mongolian grill bowl slop and the
legendary spicy calamari steak whoa what no Oh, does Oyako
don't count?
Maybe.
I don't know.
I think maybe does bullslop exist in Japan?
Japan, I feel, like, has too many things that you can't
change the menu of.
You know what I mean?
Like, they're very strict about, like, or most places, I'd
say.
Not all, but a lot of places.
they'll be strict about like this is how we make this thing
and you can't do get substitutes you can't get anything
fancy isn't ramen kind of like a bowl slop i'd say ramen's
closer to a soup in my opinion
locomuko that's a great bowl slop how much money do we got
more heat.
I'm gonna get more warmth.
I lied about...
Our warmth is maxed out, baby!
That's kind of awesome.
So soup is unable to be bowl slop.
Here's an example.
You get like some rice, you get some beans, you get some
tomatoes, you get some I don't know carrots you get some
chickpeas you get some chicken you know that's like a kind
of bowl and then maybe the place offers steak maybe the
place offers onions maybe the place offers croutons things
like that's like a kind of all different types of cheeses
that's that's peak bowl slop you want that if need more
warmth i can hold your hands page this is so
uncharacteristically forward of you
wait how much is the next wait can we afford we can afford
the fuel oh hot dog let's go
so risque
right now I'm eating ice cream bowl with three flavors that
sounds that just sounds yummy that just sounds yummy do not
tempt me I'm trying to be good before off kai I'm like you
know I should I should stop eating ice cream so much and
bubble tea instead I'm getting bowl slop with hummus and and
carrots save up so you can treat yourself yeah baby pages a
minto veteran was only a matter of time what do you mean
yeah pages been around for since like i started which
speaking of my six year anniversary is like actually when
was my first stream i'm gonna be Celebrating my anniversary
a little later than the actual day.
Because I think...
Or maybe it was it earlier.
I can't remember.
But I have a little something planned for it.
Not so much.
But because, you know, I have my anniversary plus my new
outfit.
I don't want to overload.
But also speaking of my outfit...
Oh, guys.
I'm a little worried because I'm worried that if there's
some a few things that I'm worried might not be done in
time.
I don't want to delay, but I may perhaps have to delay a few
days.
Obviously, this is not an official formal me saying I'm
delaying it, but there is a chance.
Unfortunately, we shall see.
Hopefully not, though.
I'm too excited.
I don't want to delay it.
I think after this, I'm going to be done with this area.
We can move forward with the other one.
Yep.
I think delay is better than unfinished.
Yeah, I agree, I agree.
I would much rather have everything prepared than not...
And before the new Minto outfits have to be hidden at
Offkai.
No, it should not be that bad.
If it comes down to that, I will just debut before I have to
be like that.
That would be cruel to everybody.
That would be cruel.
There's too much that...
There's too much that I would have to tell.
Like, or too many people would have to like...
That worked on things.
I would have to hide things.
That'd be terrible!
Oops.
Oh, oops.
Uh, oh.
Uh, get me out of here?
There we go.
What's over this way?
Another thing?
I hear it in here, I think.
Oh.
Oh, treasure chest!
Wait, did we get a lot of cash?
2,000, baby!
Let's go.
Hitting those notes.
Our angelic pile of...
Money.
I feel like Mr. Crabs every time I find a treasure chest in
this game.
I'm like, money.
Okay, this might be empty, yep.
Oh, what's in here?
Shut up, this was here the whole time.
Oh my god.
We could have been selling it here the whole time.
What is this?
I just had to run forward a little bit.
Lucky find.
Yeah, exactly.
Awesome.
Oh.
Oh, it's only one cold in here even.
So where are we headed to?
I've watched something recently.
You guys know I sing that song, The Wichita Line Man.
And karaoke sometimes.
I love that song.
And I was watching like a short little...
A video came up in my feed about it.
Minster Crabs.
And it was basically talking about how like the song came to
be and how some of it almost didn't come to be it's really
interesting sometimes you think about like songs like that
that sounds so like you know profound and like you know it's
like wow but you then watch something about it and it's like
it's like everything almost feels like an accident like a
happy little accident that makes it all come together so
perfectly and you're like oh you like listen to it and
you're like this must have all been like so carefully
orchestrated and planned and you know there's no way that
they didn't put so much thought into this and that and it
literally is just i feel that way sometimes when people talk
about our music videos or like like with the burn on people
were like oh they thought of this and they thought of that
And it really was just like, let's use puppets because we
can't go film anything else anymore right now.
Based on vibes.
Yeah, vibes are huge though, no?
I was supposed to be doing overtime at work on the night of
your outfit reveal, but I swapped it because...
Oh, she's more important!
Wait!
No, Phil!
I sure hope I can do it that night then.
No, I'm so sorry.
I'll still do my best.
Honestly, part of it is stuff about that I'm trying to do.
And part of it is stuff I'm waiting on.
So, I'm kind of in like a...
I left this one jutting out like that.
I'm in a bit of a...
It's not a creative rut, but...
A little bit.
Just trying to figure out how I want to do things.
Hmm.
Sometimes, usually the, my best ideas come to me, like, the
night before, hours before a stream.
It's terrible.
Talk it over with someone?
Yeah, maybe.
Maybe.
But the people I would talk to it over with are all in
Australia.
Everybody's there!
I'm really enjoying their tweets though, it's funny.
We're about to be able to upgrade our Tesla.
It's awesome.
Gotta do a handstand before you call them.
Yeah, that's the problem.
They can't understand my accent now that they're there.
They're like, huh?
Huh?
I don't even know how to do an Oasi accent.
The best idea is come on the toilet.
You should not be sitting on the toilet.
that long.
We've had this discussion.
If you sit on the toilet for so long, you're gonna get
hemorrhoids.
You have to be careful.
Truly, what about whatever happened to the best ideas come
in the shower?
We know, we know.
Do you?
Does everybody know?
I don't know.
I'm not, I'm not, I'm not hearing enough.
I'm hearing people telling me to get ideas on the I don't
know if people know how dangerous that can be for your
bottom.
Shower is peak thinking time.
No, for me, because I have so much anxiety, my peak thinking
time is like right at bedtime.
Anybody else?
Any anxiety havers over here?
Who are thinking about everything in the world?
right when it's time to sleep baby oh yeah
wow this this fuel lasts oh my gosh I'm almost dead wait I
just noticed my my chill that lasted us forever wow
unfortunately though we do have to go back through to go get
the next upgrade this is why I read before but that's a good
idea that is a good idea let's check out oh this is this one
there was another way over heat wait no oh it's just a loop
okay
is it there yeah oh wow that was smooth that was so smooth
my ceiling at 3 a.m.
has dealt with more thoughts tm than probably my whole
scholarly career that's so true i always have so many
thoughts when i'm trying to take a nap the worst is when you
sleep for an hour wake up and then it all starts up again
yeah sonic the hedgehog strictly forbids me from thinking
about life past 9 p.m but it's not even just live it's like
it's like also for me it's uh just like what i gotta do my
ideas and my things like oh i gotta i gotta work on this i
gotta do this what if we get more fuel instead
oh we maxed our fuel okay now we're gonna upgrade the test
that's why streams are great Distraction?
So true.
I love reading before bed.
It's a surefire way to fall asleep in five minutes or stay
up into 6 a.m.
There's no in-between.
So true.
Wait.
Oh, we have like just enough to get a new inventory.
Fuel is huge too though.
Hmm.
Hmm, I don't know.
Maybe I should start reading before bed.
I saw recently, like, a cute little e-reader that I was
like, this?
I think I could, like, you know, really get behind, like,
reading in bed.
If I had it, it would make it much easier.
And then...
Who was I talking about e-readers with?
Might have been NIMBY.
Oh.
Which one?
I saw one?
That seemed to be like...
It was like a...
I'm just getting the scraps away.
It was one that was a...
Magsafe.
So it kind of sticks to the back of your phone.
And people were saying that like instead of like scrolling
on their phone, they would just flip their phone over and
like read a little bit.
I don't remember what it was called though.
but I was like that's so that's so genius
the XTE X4 maybe maybe because for some people you know if
you're like so used to having your phone in your hand you
should have it you should instead have it where you um
don't scroll you just flip it over and read instead and I I
appreciate smaller size things way to check your
subconscious I think so honestly for me I find that getting
off my phone can be so difficult because I'm on it so often
for like checking Twitter and stalking your accounts and
things like that So, you know, I struggle with not just,
like, going through Twitter for that kind of stuff.
I'm lost.
I hear new music, though.
Are we in a new biome?
I talked recently about listening to a bunch of Minecraft
music recently, and I just ordered Minecraft vinyls.
I'm so excited I'm so excited to get them I want to get
Minecraft vinyls which I got and then I want to get ace
attorney vinyls if I can find one you've got them it's like
the best type of music to just chill to in your home no it
sounds awesome you guys gotta romanticize things a That's
what I've been trying to do.
You romanticize your afterlife to, you know, to make just
the small things more enjoyable.
Suspense background.
Unfortunately, chicken death was not on it.
Chicken death is not on it, which is, like, shocking to me.
Inject a little romance.
Yeah.
Were you also stalking the likes tab when it was public
before?
Yes.
I'm so sad the likes tab.
I want people to stalk my likes tab because I always felt I
liked really good things.
I liked really good stuff.
Now I'm sad people can't see it.
Cleaning up.
Yes, nice and neat.
Nice and neat.
We found some gems in there before.
No way.
Wait, you guys actually looked?
I miss stalking your likes tab.
I also think that it's so funny that, like, you know, back
in the day when likes were still public, there would be,
like, a sexy picture, and the likes would be like moderate,
but the bookmarks would be go crazy.
It was so funny.
I bookmark, well, I bookmark, like, sometimes, like, things
that I see.
If I see, like, a good artist, I'll bookmark them, because I
want to be, like, maybe I can work with you later or
something.
That was pretty funny, though.
I'm like, you cowards!
Like it with your own account!
Why are you?
Not just liking it or yeah, why just just be a freak and be
proud It's okay.
It's okay.
Like on main I do
Wait, is this another staircase?
Oh, I think it's oh it is wait, is it?
Okay,
our cold is going quite down but But we might be able to
almost have enough to upgrade soon.
Come on, come on.
Oh, nice.
Get more stuff.
Let's go.
I leave a comment to let the world know I liked it.
That's a great idea.
Heartbreaking my three-year-old outdated Twitter app doesn't
reply to tweets and load images and show ludes anymore.
No!
Wow, you're the strongest soldier page.
Not updating for three years.
I may guide you some burritos!
Thank you, Eric.
Thank you.
Okay, one more shot and we should be able to upgrade our
Tesla.
I just kind of want to go up the stairs though.
Yummy burrito.
Boruto, Boruto.
Boruto, Boruto, Boruto, Boruto.
Naruto, Naruto.
Boruto's dead, Boruto's dead.
Boruto's dead.
Naruto, Naruto, Boruto, Boruto, Boruto, Boruto.
Boruto, Boruto.
I should get a burrito.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
What's like a, what's your, what's like a Saturday meal to
you guys?
It's a good Saturday food.
Pizza Friday.
Taco Tuesday.
Burritos are so rap slop.
Yeah, everything is a slop.
Everything is a slop.
Tonkats!
Burger?
Burger Saturday is...
Okay.
I'll give you... Actually, I can take a burger any day of
the week.
I'll take a burger anytime.
Anywhere.
I also have a really awesome burger place by me as well.
I don't know, I really like my new area.
I really like my new place.
Smash burgers are peak Oh, I just realized my
Yahoo!
Let's go back
Why does this look like I can do something with it, you
know?
I don't think I can, but
Burgers are just bun slop You know what?
Maybe slop is okay Maybe we like slop Slop Okay Slop is
great!
I'm not afraid to say I love slop.
Friend slop.
Anime slop.
Yeah, I love slop.
Slop affectionate, exactly.
I wonder if this will like upgrade so so much, you know?
Mint slop!
Upgrade the Tesla gun three times.
Electrification.
we get spam emails that are like, hello my perverted friend,
we have access to your history and webcam.
Pay us Bitcoin or else, and we're all, oh no, people
literally care so much.
Hello my perverted friend.
Wait, I should start all business emails like that.
Maybe the real line to cross was, if you use a trough, Huh?
Hello, my perverted friend.
That is...
What a...
What a... What a catch.
Like, what a... You know, like the catch to an email.
It's crazy work.
So funny.
Ah!
Aw, man.
I almost had it.
I almost was Spider-Man, for real.
Do it!
I'm just gonna you know how you can make like headers for
your and like footers for your emails I'm just gonna do that
I'm just gonna like write it so it's automatically into my
email every time one thing I wish this game had was I was
able to read the lore and like whatever these what does this
say this is so mysterious you know I can't type today if we
eat slop from oh
should say.
They're like the ones on Twitch.
People get really creative with those.
Mine would say.
Um.
Hello, pervert.
Time for stream.
Are sloppy Joe's burger slap?
Or are the burgers...
Or the burgers sloppy slopsception?
Too much slop.
Uh-oh.
Wait, we're reaching critical Slop levels.
Not even the sloppy sisters can reach these slop levels.
Wait?
Yippee!
Freedom!
Let's open this up a little bit more.
I feel like an alien when I use this.
Glor blob globe.
Oh, are we coming in peace?
Are we coming beans what's going on in here oh this is where
we need to go
i am peace dang i didn't know your name was pacifica ocean
pies dang wait there's another there's two what there's two
oh this one's a yellow
peace the beast
how far do you think i can get
Wait, does it end here?
I'm gonna go back.
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
We can make it.
About these far.
Oh, wait, we're so close.
Yeah, until we hit the wall.
Which we totally didn't do.
Yeah, it's okay.
But be cool.
Where the fuck is this?
Hey y'all, me doll!
Have you been well?
You too, Artemis!
Thank you so much for 21 Monteroos!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
We're heading this way first.
But unfortunately, our ribbon has...
Oh!
Wait, we're going down!
Uh oh.
We're going down, down!
Yum yum yum yum!
Oh wait?
I mean, though, melting inhibitions away.
Not the inhibitions.
Come on, I'm getting this more cleared up.
Oh, oh.
Maybe this way.
I see something over here.
A passage, perhaps.
I really wish I could make my...
more.
I want more warmth.
There's a... Is this...
There's also this way.
What is this way?
Whoa!
There's too many directions, guys.
I can't choose.
Just keep going.
Keep going straight.
Straight forward.
Up the stairs.
Oh!
Wait.
Oh.
I went in a circle.
No way.
That was just a circle?
Why didn't they warn me?
I'm gonna go back.
Does this game have multiplayer?
It should.
It honestly should.
It'd be so fun.
Multiplayer would be awesome.
We're making...
We're already halfway to being able to upgrade our Tesla gun
again.
That's great.
That's good.
Good news.
Let's go through our hole again.
It is much slower getting stuff now though, isn't it?
Is this still...
Is this...
Oh, it is to a wall.
Aw, lame.
Then you can hug your homie for warmth!
Wait, that's so sweet!
Homie, homie, I can't feel my toes!
I got you, dude.
I got you.
Come here, let me give you a big warm, big warm hug.
Yeah, and you take off your clothes because, you know, when
you take off your clothes, you transfer the body better,
right?
Take off your clothes with the homies if you're cold.
Oh, more!
More loops.
More loops?
I'm gonna place a thing here.
Where are we?
Can I die down there?
I hope not.
Any cold-eye-boo in chat?
Actually, there's research that says it's worse.
What?
I learned from Love Hina.
Wait, what are you talking about?
It can't be worse.
I learned from Love Hina.
I learned from my anime.
I thought you'd take off your clothes.
I think somebody just has no one to get naked with.
I learned from anime that you can do this.
Why else would they do it?
They have no other reason to have her get naked otherwise,
right?
Wait, was it Love Hina or was it the other Ken Akamatsu?
What was the one?
A.I.
Love You.
Did anybody read that one?
Actually, I read that one before Love Hina, I think.
No, not Negima.
Though it is like a common trope.
You did!
A true OG fan.
I mean...
Our inventory is full?
Oh my gosh, I don't think we've seen that message in a long
time.
That's crazy.
This is a good sound.
You're very cultured, Mint.
Am I?
I don't know.
At that time, I was reading all like these robot girl minds.
manga i read a i love you i read video girl i i loved video
girl i oh my gosh i loved i read chobits i think at that
time i don't know maybe robot girls were just super in or
something
video girl i is fantastic yeah i've watched that Probably
should not have been watching that.
I shouldn't have been reading any of that at the...
Whatever.
Yeah, you know, it's fine.
I turned out fine, probably.
Turned out fine, probably.
It's okay, we all did it.
Exactly, exactly.
Whoopsie.
Oh wait, there was another way we could go, wasn't there?
Hold on.
Uh, it wasn't this, was it?
There was like a...
It is this way, it is this way.
Right?
Because we've kind of run out of places to go, otherwise.
I think.
Have robot girls ever not been in?
So true.
Robot girls are amazing.
That's so true.
That's so true though, right?
I did not turn out fine.
I turned out freaky.
They both start with F.
Sounds good to me.
Close enough.
Yeah, close enough.
We take those, we take those.
Where are we headed.
Oh my gosh, it was another circle.
Are we kidding right now?
No.
Wait.
Maybe this wasn't the one that... Huh?
Wait, how did I do that?
Not noticed.
Wait.
I like curly braids from Cave Story.
She's cute.
Wait, I don't know.
Was there another one that...
I thought there was another one I missed, no?
We might have enough to upgrade the gun.
Roll from Mega Man is very cute, I agree.
Multi is cute, yes, multi is very cute.
Oh wait, I forgot to sell.
Do we have enough?
You just barely.
Nice.
Oh yeah.
It's so great to meet you at Smash yesterday!
Can't wait for the concert tonight.
Big reach!
See you!
See you at the concert!
Yes, yes, yes.
I feel like right now I need a map.
Hold on.
Let's go back through.
We'll find where we were at.
We'll find it.
In fact, I'm gonna go this way.
Oh, oh, I'm surprised I made that it.
XJ9.
Gosh, robot girls are so awesome.
Robots are so awesome!
If we come across a pathway, that splits.
No!
Wait.
Up here, maybe.
Oh, oh, yes.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
We went the yellow way.
Here we go.
More into the abyss.
Yes, yes.
This is good.
Oh, this is great.
Wait.
What is this?
The shovel!
E to shovel?
E?
A.
The shovel!
Find a shovel.
How well does it work?
Oh.
Not at all.
Wait!
Oh!
Like, crazy?
It's a little slow, but...
Huh.
Interesting.
I think, honestly, using our test list still is better.
We're gonna want to go heat up.
There was also a place to dig in one of the areas, I
remember.
Hold on.
Let's go head back a little bit ways.
Yeah, we're gonna upgrade it to set on fire.
Trust.
I guess you can use it when you have no Energy.
Oh wait, I think I went the wrong way.
That's alright though.
Gotta say I prefer Chobitz's anime ending over the manga
ending.
I feel like it's usually the other way around with me for
original endings.
I'm trying to remember the anime ending.
I don't think I remember it.
I remember the manga ending, but I don't remember the anime
ending.
Flaming shovel.
A better way.
There was.
Is it over here?
Yes.
Where are we?
What are we digging to?
There's so much to explore.
Who?
Ha!
This guy cracks me up.
Green.
flags.
Green flag all around.
No red flags here.
New area or something.
Hot dog indeed.
Yen way, thank you.
The game's called Melopia, but who is Mel and who are they
going to top?
Oh, Mel topping you.
That's what you're confused with.
Which that is a game that you can only see if you...
set your Steam settings to see all games.
Wait, am I going the right way, this way?
This is a common mistake that people make, you know.
Where are we going, guys?
The items in here are pretty cheap, but you have to, you
have to have the shovel to get down here, so clearly this is
like a Later game area or something
I want that game now Mel topping ya It's the most wishless
game On scene don't you hear
Where are we going Yeah, I know my inventory is full I'm
trying to make a proper path.
Oh.
More green flags.
We're going down.
Following the flags.
Is it money?
Is it ice cube?
Ice cube.
There's someone...
Meeting you yesterday.
Thank you for being human.
Thank you, Dad.
Thank you!
Thanks for coming to see us!
I searched but Kuro Inu 2 Redux came up.
Thank you.
Oh, you're welcome.
Bone or artifact?
Bone, bone, bone, bone, bone!
Artifact?
Wait.
No, it's a bone.
Hold on, I'm gonna turn it down because Oh, yes.
The floating tusks.
Nice.
Nice tusks.
Wait.
Shovel is...
The shovel is perfect as is.
Needs no upgrades.
Needs nothing.
It is perfect.
As it is.
Yeah, the shovel doesn't lock.
Not the shovel.
The thumbnail doesn't lie.
Wait.
How much is it to upgrade the Tesla next?
$13,000.
Sorry.
Let's grab a new fuel tank.
Let's go back this way.
We had so much stuff that we left in here.
And also, I don't quite think we're done in this area.
Okay.
Thank you!
I think there's more to see here.
Hopefully?
Oh, uh, maybe not.
Maybe we got everything.
My inventory's already full!
Hold on, I'm just checking around the edges.
See, this looks like it goes in more, no?
This is actually going quite deep.
There's definitely more to it.
Oh, or maybe?
Maybe not.
That was really satisfying, right?
We'll have it happen again.
It'll happen again.
I know all those little pickup sounds.
It's great.
Hmm.
I mean, it would make sense.
Wait, wait.
This is a strange structure, huh?
It would make sense that there's only the tusks in there.
Or not.
I don't know, it's still going.
Maybe it's just a funny structure.
Very very interesting.
Very interesting.
Oh, uh, how do
I...
Don't get too cold.
We're gonna, we're gonna make it.
We're gonna make it.
I trust
Trust We're fine We're fine
There we go I wasn't panicking Don't panic I wasn't
panicking We weren't panicking We were not panicking Okay
13,000 and then for more inventory.
I think I'll hold off for now.
100 is still pretty dang good.
Who's panicking?
Not me.
That's for sure.
Look at that.
Easy peasy.
Stuff.
That's the sound.
we liked it here.
Oh no, walls!
Wait, is this really it?
It's just a giant room in here, that's it.
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
My inventory is full already.
Wait, I hear something else.
It's behind the wall.
We go this way?
How do I get over there?
Is there a way around?
It's like right there.
To my right.
Huh?
I don't think I can get there.
Oh, it's even louder.
Or not louder, but higher.
How do I get to you?
My angel of music!
I don't know how.
It's like, no.
Bozo.
Hmm.
Find them, oh, the meat cafe is here.
Inside of my mind.
Oh, hey.
I think you appear in her mirror and kidnap her.
We could.
That's weird, though.
I think there was a forking path just before that wall.
Perhaps.
Perhaps there was.
We'll go give it another shot.
Oh, come on.
Don't be like that.
Oh, don't be like that.
Let's see.
Maybe, like, over here-ish?
We start...
Going this way.
Or...
Maybe it's, like, an entirely different way.
Okay.
I mean, we already have a new way we were trying.
We found that one big castle.
I want to go back in there, too.
There's too much to explore.
It's so much fun.
Mito has melted my cold heart.
And pant?
Why are your pants cold?
What does that mean?
Single pant.
Oh, I made a...
whole circle.
Guys, I'm not sure about this one.
Maybe it's like you get it in a different location.
Kind of hard to say at the moment.
It's a little hard to say.
Yeah.
This is... wait.
This is the way... yeah, this is the way home.
I went all through here there is none no deviating path do
you want help help help help like
a hint wait do you know do you some of you know i was gonna
go back here honestly i think i wanted to go back to this
place because it was pretty neat where was it though oh wait
i think the other way was technically faster let's heat up
okay there we go no no no no no oh whoa whoa i don't know
how that happens
yes yes yes hint phantom probably a different streamer um
please refer to the rules in the description of the stream
the rules and the description please don't mention under
other streamers unless I bring them up hint phantom is my
nemesis and actually it's really bad that you bring her up
what if there's a room up here I feel like there is anyone
else feel like there's a room up here or just me yeah hint
phantom They... they... they...
They stole my lunch money.
What?
How?
You dig here.
You can dig to here.
Wait, that's crazy work.
Wait, how do we dig here?
What?
Another?
Am I on it?
I'm on it.
How much money?
1400 stingy what poor guy left his his stinky chest over
here Wow I will though head back and and warm up some I got
a warm up after that that made my heart Hi, it's me,
Hint-Hint-Panthome.
I actually love you.
You were my inspiration to be a VTuber.
Now you're just gonna...
Now you're just gonna guilt me!
I'm gonna...
Don't tell them about how I used to steal your lunch money.
Hinto wouldn't bulk at a small treasure.
all right let's go back back
into the frozen castle don't tell them yeah don't tell them
all right we're just gonna go we're just gonna go straight
forward see if we can find another oh hey wait a second is
this really it
This isn't what we saw in that other room, is it?
Because that'd be awkward.
I sure would be awkward, huh, guys?
Holy shit.
That's not blood.
That's my uniform.
Guys, that's not blood.
That's my suit.
That's not blood.
Digging through chocolate.
It does kind of look delicious, huh?
Oh.
We're digging.
I gotta be careful in my...
Wait.
My heat, though.
My warmth.
We're still going?
Please?
I don't know why it doesn't work sometimes.
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Parkour!
Oh my gosh.
Get me out of here.
Wait, we're still...
We're so far from home, though.
Spider-Man, no way home.
Wait, we're so far from home.
Actually.
I don't know if we're gonna make it, guys.
Oh.
Oh, not up there.
Oh, gosh.
I'm freezing.
Guys, this is pretty bad.
This is pretty bad.
This could be bad.
This could be real bad.
This could be the best, the baddest, bad, bad.
Wait, we're almost there.
Oh, yes!
Yes!
I made it!
Oh, that was close!
Okay.
Nice.
The grapple is crazy.
I'm gonna save.
I keep forgetting to save.
Hmm.
Oh yeah!
Alright.
Fill my energy.
There we go.
Okay.
Just in case.
Um, the red I think it was that you cannot...
Uh...
grapple it?
So, let's just go in.
Let's see what we can do.
I'm fastest freak, boy.
I'm fastest freak.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
We're fast as freak, we're fast as freak.
And here, it's just dropping into the ground.
Oh, oh, that was close.
All right, we got a good amount going on.
Oh, okay, great start.
It was fine.
Did I make it?
Oh,
the music got creepy.
Ooh.
Yeah, okay.
I don't think I can grapple at all in here.
Wait, where do I go?
Up?
Where?
Oh, yes.
Ouch.
Right there.
Gamers don't look up.
An ice cube all the way here?
What am I supposed to do with this?
Uh, uh...
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Can I go up?
There's nothing there.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
My ice cube!
Oh, I have to drop it to dig.
Okay?
No, come on.
Don't do this to me.
Come on.
Come on, game.
Yeah, okay, all right.
A little in the way.
Getting cold.
Oh gosh.
No!
Oh my gosh, please.
Where are we?
Oh, we're here!
Oh my god.
Like, get me out!
Get me out of here!
We can- we made it before!
We can do it again!
We made it before!
We're- we're fine, we're totally okay.
We made it, we made it.
Oh!
Alright.
From here though, now I'm actually like...
Where...
Do I go?
You know, cause...
Now I'm really feeling like we're running out of places to
search.
I think.
Maybe...
Maybe.
That was me getting home today on 1% car battery!
You're lucky we didn't go up any hills.
Maybe you did, I don't know.
Hmm.
Yeah, we're missing way too many bones, exactly.
More bone!
What is that?
The tiniest rib cage ever.
Oh yeah!
Coming along nicely.
I guess.
There's also so many artifacts that we haven't caught in.
What's that?
Oh, what are you?
What is that?
Can't tell.
Candles?
Maybe.
Hmm.
What a mysterious place.
Like, is this my house?
Whose house is this um what was this 13 000 we're so close
let me go see over here if there was anything
not quite what was in here oh this is when we got the
grappling hook but there's also remember i think it was here
this area yeah Which we haven't been able to explore.
How do we get up there?
Right?
We can just go back through some old areas and see if there
was anything that we couldn't get before.
Maybe some places to dig that I didn't notice before.
The super cold places, yeah, there were a couple of those as
well.
I forgot about this guy.
So, this was a super cold place.
Yeah, I think we should try this one out.
Just chilling.
Okay.
We'll try this one.
This place is, like, mega cold, though.
Hopefully, we don't have to dig too far.
Oh, wait.
It turns to two after a while.
Yeah, we definitely haven't gone any further in here, so...
But so far, no...
Angelic noise.
Hmm.
Oh!
Angelic noise!
I'm stuck in a hole.
I hear it.
It's so close.
It's right underneath us.
It's right above us.
It's right next to us.
It's around this wall.
Probably.
You think it's money?
I think it's a nice cube!
Nice.
I can't always be money or else we'll never find any
artifacts.
This is a bone.
It's...
Oh.
What was it?
Zab!
He's freaky.
What the heck?
Which one?
Do you want me to...
Which...
Oh, place the Aztec mask here.
Oh, this place is cursed as hell.
Wait, now my achievement says find the Mayan mask.
Is it Mayan or is it Aztec?
Why not both?
Like I spit all over my...
All over me.
Well, now I'm disappointed.
I don't even know what upgrade.
I think maybe upgrading the stove kind of helps with the...
Oh, we're so close.
Making all the areas a bit warmer, perhaps, I wonder.
Hmm.
Maria, maybe.
I think we can fast travel there.
I doubt there's a second ice cube, but we can at least
check.
Check.
Ooh, chili.
Chili, chili, chili.
And we'll get enough to upgrade our gun at least.
There might also be like a further road is what I'm hoping.
No way.
This one's gotta be a treasure chest.
What?
No way!
maybe this one is a bone
no it's an upgrade i think yeah
interesting stove part and we get cash for that Tesla gun
upgrade nice 15,000 that might be the That might be the
limit, though.
Let's go back in there, I guess.
First up.
Let's go back in here.
Check out our new gun.
It doesn't feel much different than the previous one, to be
honest.
A little better.
It's actually quite a bit better.
huh yeah this is sick there
can't be a third one that would be ludicrous but there could
be maybe another pathway that leads to the third one or
something oh wait i made that wait i'm in circle wait i'm
lost oh i made a big old circle circle.
Whoopsie!
What about this way?
We could just clear out the area then, baby.
There might be a third one.
And stuff.
We made a circle.
Let's keep going this way.
Yeah, we gotta keep the moon to the left of me, or to the
right of me, all right.
We'll come back, we'll come back, we'll come back.
We'll come back.
I wanted a mid-hub.
This little light of mine.
I'm gonna let it shine.
This little light on mine.
I don't know why I checked that.
Just maybe if it has a discount on Tuesdays or something.
First off.
Oh my gosh, there is a third one in there, you guys!
This is crazy!
Now we're Spider-Manning.
Alright, how did I get there though?
Here.
Ice cube?
Oh, a third cube!
No stinking way.
High risk, high reward.
Truly.
Wow, I can't believe there's so many in here.
I mean, it's not even that high risk.
Oh, come on.
We're making crazy progress.
This has to be a mammoth piece.
They gave us an artifact.
They gave us an upgrade.
And then they gave us a mammoth piece!
Find five mammoth bone.
Out of how many?
nice
we could do the inventory now but I almost want to keep
saving for the Tesla since it's just one more it's a little
there we go it's just one more upgrade I think that we can
get yeah I think at the start of the stream we only had two
bones so we found three more in sub two hours?
Let's go.
I wonder where else we can go though.
What was back here?
We went through here.
I've gone through here.
What was down here?
What was around here?
Gone through here.
You can can see when I used to have the like the very poor
Tesla gun because it's like the the ways the passageways are
extremely small oh my gosh it's a treasure chest I was about
to scream though open 10 chests what the heck oh that's
right there's this way you think we can make
This doesn't heat me up though, unfortunately.
Unless there's like a room right here.
There might be.
I think I'll die though if I don't find one fast.
Let's just keep going.
More, more, more, yeah.
More, more, more.
Come on, come on, come on.
Come on, how much further can this be?
How much further are you?
Okay, that's great at all, but like I need a safe room.
Oh my gosh, no.
No, it didn't lead to a room.
It didn't lead to a room, you guys.
Wait.
This could be bad.
This could be really bad.
This could be very, very, very bad.
We're here!
Oh, we made it!
My gosh!
That was scary.
That was so scary.
Holy cow.
That was a very close one, huh?
The skull!
Yeah, clutch for real.
Close.
What the?
I just gained an item.
I think sometimes the items may glitch and they like end up
here.
Let's save and then go back in there.
Because there might be another one.
High risk, high reward.
Am I right, baby?
Let's go.
I find it really annoying that this thing doesn't heat you
up, you know?
I mean like it should I feel I feel like it should heat you
up because otherwise like it's still burning scam furnace
yeah I
don't know how there could be another direction but there
could be we're just hoping and praying and if anything we're
getting lots of money so Yay money.
Yeah, there really isn't anything else in here.
What the heck?
No way.
That's unbelievable.
There's nothing?
Hopes and prayers.
I mean, it is like a small little room.
So you can just come in and collect cash.
Dang.
Wait?
Wait!
It pays to explore!
No way.
Oh, my heat.
I can't mess around anymore.
Go, go, go, go, go, go!
Yes!
An acorn.
Are we in like a post-apocalyptic world that even an acorn
gets a pedestal?
You know?
It says giant acorn.
What a beautiful night.
Squail.
This is an Ice Age reference.
Could very well be.
We'll wait.
We'll still get the...
Tesla upgrade.
It's just 5,000 more.
We can go back in there and probably...
There's probably a third one, just like the other area.
You know what I mean?
There's probably a third one.
It's probably...
One chest.
One mammoth.
One artifact.
Oh, that was scary.
Oh, oh, geez, I'm stuck.
Please stop.
Let me out.
I'm stuck.
Did I get the chest already?
I don't know if I did.
Yes.
More money.
Where did I get the...
I don't know where I got the...
The ice cube, the acorn ice cube from.
My inventory's full already?
Crazy work.
There's still so much that we have to collect.
The Tesla works great now, though, isn't it?
Awesome.
It works just like the previous flamethrower with how fast
it melts stuff now.
So good.
Quite still.
I
think we oughta leave.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Oh, I'll leave.
No, not up.
Uh, Michael?
I think we'll make it.
Yeah.
We're warm.
I don't know.
Do I go in one more time?
Was there any... There was that one that we couldn't hear,
or we could hear and we couldn't get in this area.
I don't know.
I haven't seen anywhere to dig.
Hmm.
Upgrades are effective.
They are.
It's awesome.
At least grab the money.
That's true.
It's easy money.
We can just go in and go out.
Actually, I...
It's not worth it.
I was going to say I'm going to do the money upgrade, but...
I don't think it's worth it.
Oh my goodness.
I'm hitting every...
It's like when you hit every red light.
Trying to go home.
There was that over there.
Yeah, because we got the chest.
Actually... Oh, shoot.
You know, maybe we did grab everything because we got one
chest.
We got...
We got a chest?
We got the mammoth.
Maybe we did grab everything, then.
The chest artifact mammoth.
Yeah, I think so.
Melt this for whenever I inevitably land on it again.
Oh.
Melt this to make it a little easier, too.
Yeah, we got...
can always come back.
I'm just, now I'm kind of like, where else can I go?
I'm sure there's places that I missed, but I'm also
wondering where those places are.
Do we have them?
We're so close!
So close!
There's one if you don't have the crowbar.
There's a crowbar?
We need a crowbar?
Like for this?
Huh?
Crowbar?
I need a crowbar?
Hold on.
We can get this easy, guys.
We can get this easy.
Watch.
There's so much here.
Yeah.
We got this easy.
This almost feels like a separate path.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
I'm not sure.
I'm not sure where to go now though.
Not sure what areas I missed.
I think I have enough now.
One man's junk is another man's treasure, am I right?
This almost feels like its own pathway too.
Wait a second.
This feels, this is going pretty deep.
Shut up.
If
I were playing, I'd probably get tunnel vision trying to
clear out one whole side area at a time.
It's really hard not to.
Wait.
This is new...
Where am I?
Wait.
Oh, shoot.
The first time you said, seems like a separate path.
Seems like it was a separate...
what the heck how did i miss i mean it's not actually i was
gonna say how did i miss all this but it's pretty easy to
miss it i fear when your gun is not very good right upgrade
the stove to the max
is this our teslas to the max we'll get more inventory
Oh, okay.
I don't know what it does, to be honest.
Was this the area?
So easy to get lost in the sauce in here, for real.
This is...
Oh, it's just a circle, though.
It's just a circle.
To where we were.
But this is still...
Okay, never mind.
We got this.
Okay.
that's so funny though how it's it's kind of it feels a
little tricky finding these no like some of these are really
like you you have to be like yeah I'm going I'm digging up
everything max Tesla is awesome yeah yeah Hmm.
But there's more.
We know there's more.
Trying to think of where we should go.
It's basically it, yeah.
You have to want to clean the whole room.
Should I go back into the other area then?
Is there more?
It's so hard to say.
A lot of mammoth left.
to assure her.
That didn't feel like there was anything else in the other
room, but now?
I don't know!
Why not?
Okay.
I don't...
Because I think, for the most part, maybe we've...
Well, I can't say that.
Maybe we've discovered every area.
Like, main area, maybe?
That's what I'm trying to say.
Imagine there's an achievement...
Oh, shoot.
For melting every pixel of ice oh shoot i'm stuck i think it
would have to be a what's it called i mean there might be
but i feel like in that kind of situation it would have to
be like a you know how in um power wash simulator when you
clean enough it'll like get rid of a lot more stuff like
it'll you know you just have to clean like a certain
percentage of the area before it auto cleans it would i feel
like it would really want otherwise you might actually go
insane trying to find the single last pixel or each room i
feel like would have to tell you like this is this is how
much is left you know you've cleaned a hundred percent of it
or something there's nothing left in there there's sometimes
the machines the tesla gun sounds like it's doing the, you
know.
Maybe this way?
Aw, mean.
Cleaning the whole room.
She's finally completing her maidly duties.
I do that every day.
Oh, my.
Getting chilly.
Oh, oh,
oh, oh, we got this.
Yeah, we're fine.
Let's go get more inventory.
So close.
I'm going to go to the first stop again.
There is this area.
As much as I feel like we've cleared it out, What was this
one again?
What was up here?
A whole lot of nothing.
Unless I cleaned it that well.
I don't think I would.
Oh, it's this area.
With the dead body.
Oh, yeah, this is the white snow.
Yeah, like, even still here.
It looks almost- we're so used to the blue snow.
Seeing the white snow is like, whoa.
I'm at a loss of where to go though.
Give me the map.
I think we just did a big old circle.
As long as it's not the yellow snow.
That's in the DLC.
Need a hint?
Sure.
At this point, yeah, I'll take a hint.
I'll take a hint.
If anybody knows.
Hint, Phantom.
Yeah, you have to acquire a housemat suit to deal with the
yellow snow.
There's a dirt at the second stop.
There is?
Is this dirt?
Oh my god!
Ooh, we're easy.
Easy.
I was wondering, I saw these red...
I was like, oh maybe they're like of, you know, past...
You know, I was like, oh maybe it's...
leftover thing.
I mean, I should have known that like a caven can just be
blast it away right thank you oh there's more stuff up in
the ceiling thank you you too thank you you too grab some
items yeah um i will head back sell them
all right fill that up oh dang it i was hoping for our
inventory i was hoping that That would be enough.
Save reminder.
Thank you.
I was gonna save right before we went into here though.
Yes.
The texture did look like muddy slush.
Right?
That's why I thought it wasn't able to go through.
I was a fool!
Wait, now is this the blue stuff?
Oh.
I hear one.
This one looks fancy, guys.
This one looks extra special.
We're gonna get...
We're right next to it, so I'm gonna clear out as much as
possible.
And then...
Wait.
Continue.
Clear out as much as possible.
This room's cool.
Literally.
It's so cool.
What's up, wait.
What's a bear?
I don't know if I can grasp it.
It's yelling at me.
It's like, please pick up the stone.
Let's see.
Cute?
Oh yeah, I didn't think so.
Give me a second.
I'm working here.
There's definitely like another passageway over here.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, wow.
I inventory is full.
Once we buy everything, what's even the point of money?
Right?
Hold on.
I did nothing.
Come with me.
Wait, can I?
Oh, there we go.
Many are saying this.
Whoa.
What is this?
The triceratops school?
The bedazzled triceratops school?
Look at them chompers.
Yay!
Upgrade the backpack to the max!
We've upgraded!
Time to blow her up, baby.
Yeah!
Let's head back.
Oh, that's how I much pressure.
We'll save again because it's quite cold in here.
It's very, very frigid.
Uh-huh!
Oh.
Oh my items!
Wait, what if we do like up top.
Come on.
I give up.
Oh my gosh.
I'm forgetting my controls.
Okay, at least we're out of the super frigidness.
I suspect you have no upper body strength.
I have an inkling of a...
of a thought as well.
the same idea yes i i do believe that might be the case
maybe we are a weak little baby what is that oh nothing wait
oh i
think i can get warm in here hot jokes on you bozo you sure
thought
You sure thought that the fire would keep you warm.
Um, oh,
it's so dark.
Can't these fires keep me warm?
Oh, that's it!
Wait, that's literally it?
There was nothing to do in there at all.
Wait, that's crazy work.
It was just all puzzle.
okay that's fine all
right we got a rip cage going on so close to connecting so
close I'm not quite sure where else to go that that was much
faster than I thought it would be that was much faster than
I thought it would be I guess we can collect that we can get
rid of the rest of it huh i'm gonna be so rich and i'm gonna
have nothing to spend my money on i'm gonna be so rich
nothing to spend my money on i'm gonna get bored and start
buying spaceships and stuff man oh it looks so pretty when
it's like super dark Are those like items in there?
No?
Oh, maybe.
So cool.
If I had money, so much money, that I didn't know what to do
with it, I would fund whoever is trying to bring Jurassic
Park.
But I would say as an investor, as a top bidding investor, I
would say, now.
You can make Jurassic Park, but you have to make sure you
breed them.
You bring them back as all little minis.
T-Rex?
Two feet max.
One foot.
One foot tall.
Ketzel Kauatlas.
I can fit him in my room.
You know?
That is a bad idea.
No, that's why I think it.
That's why it's a good idea, because they're so small.
So you want a chicken?
Yes.
If you have extra money, you could throw Super Chats at
VTubers.
Chicken Ketzel.
Chickens don't walk with their wings, though.
I love that part about the Ketzel.
It's so cute.
Ketzel the size of a small cat.
Probably will do just the amount of damage.
Guys, you don't have to be scared of the ketzel.
It'll just pierce you.
But it won't be able to eat you.
Its throat is too small.
Where else can we go?
We came from this way.
And I don't know at all.
Anything else to do in this game.
missing mammoth parts ain't that a shame what else do we do
in this game hmm we need to make a minto game minto's
Jurassic pets with exclamations many exclamations thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you thank you and thank
you also i i only commented on mutabulus thank you
YouTubers, like you just did.
Was there anything else in here?
Did I go up here?
Oh, clearly.
Wait, what's down here then?
Oh, it connects.
That's right.
Where's the ice monkey?
In our hearts?
In our minds?
We're always thinking of ice monkey.
Did we ever find anything down in the dig hole?
There has to be something down there.
There's like a thing that we can't, that we can only hear
but we can't get to.
We can try going back though.
Oh wait, this is wrong.
Over this way.
I'm quite at a loss though, currently.
Minto, why is Iceland green and Greenland icy?
Because...
they are we're a little quirky and they said they said we're
gonna they said literally they're like we're gonna paint
this place green we're gonna paint it green it's gonna be
awesome can i open this door no i don't know if you'd play
it before but i think you can tame a quetzal a quetzal a
pretzel an arc arc before.
Definitely heard of it.
That game is so intensive, though.
That game is crazy.
There's another game that I heard of recently.
Wait, hold on.
Let me see the name of it.
I said I liked it the other way.
Where is it?
Oh, this.
The aisle.
Oh, yeah, you knew.
I think I had also heard of that one before too though.
I just haven't gotten around to playing it yet.
Let's go to Area 1.
Was it...
Or the main hub.
Everything I've heard about Arc is that like...
If you play Arc casually, you are not playing Arc correctly.
You know?
Like there are no casual Arc players.
You're not allowed.
Okay.
sure very sweaty game yeah yeah yeah yeah all right we're
gonna start getting us the whole area again
the aisle is also that way no it looks so fun though
i still can hear it there's something there is it above us
No, it's definitely behind this wall.
I don't know what they want me to do.
Like...
To get it.
Oh.
Hold.
That's why we couldn't get to it.
Oh my gosh, even more.
Oh, there it is.
Seems like that's all that's in here, though, maybe.
Okay.
I like when it starts getting impatient at you.
And it's like, please.
Please take me home.
Please.
Uh-oh.
There we go.
And now I'm washed.
Is this the way home?
I get it, I messed up.
We fought, it was just in the ginormous area that I didn't
check.
Who would have thought it'd be in the ginormous area that I
didn't check?
Who would have thought that?
Minto is loss.
Did she just call me loss?
What is this?
Place the Aztec knife here.
Find the Mayan dagger.
The game and the achievements are fighting.
I got bull slop!
Let's go!
Of course Minto understands the ancient runes.
Of course.
Look, we've gotten so many...
Is there anything up here?
No, this is just where we admire our handiwork.
What's over here?
So we need two more here.
Oh.
It's cold here.
What is that place?
What about the other side?
Actually, how do I even get to this side?
Like this.
Oh, this place is huge!
here too I don't know how that's possible when my stove is
maxed but sure whatever game huh oh grapple to it I guess
you're right right I use my I use my legs I don't need no
dang frown grappling hook I can I can use my legs.
They're good for boasting.
Legs.
But yeah, we only need two...
Four.
Three!
Only three more artifacts left.
And...
Just the few bones that are left.
That's it.
Where else, though?
I don't feel like there's gonna be anything else down there.
about three bones really is that all you think i can't tell
if you're like if you pulled that number out of your butt or
not i honestly though if anybody wants to give another hint
hint hint hint the tiny sliver of pixels at the bottom of me
oh you're right i don't even notice that i'll fix it
There we go.
Whoops.
There's one bone and artifact at the first stop.
One bone and one artifact.
I haven't gotten?
At the first stop.
One bone and one artifact.
In here?
Where are it?
I believe you because we're We barely cleared out this
thing, I feel like.
You know?
There might be another secret down tunnel like the other
one.
Or just...
The tunnels are so sneaky, you know?
You feel like you wouldn't see it.
Like, you wouldn't feel like it keeps going, but it suddenly
dies.
Wait a second.
Where does this lead to?
Okay.
Wait, okay.
Where does this lead to?
We're going?
You were flying!
Just like in today's translated Good Morning Minto.
The translations are so funny.
They're cracking me up.
No!
The translations have been cracking me up recently.
I'm really looking forward to cracking up.
It's been a while since I last cracked up.
If we make a grand discovery, though, we might have to go
back anyway to refuel and such.
Refuel.
Well, we don't have to refuel, but get our heat back up.
The translations are so funny, though.
I don't know why they do them, but I'm here for it.
My ghostly cow moji.
Oh, there's no refuel here.
Oh, lame.
I love to throw self at you.
So funny!
You're so funny, so funny.
Oh, let's sell too, I guess.
Hum, hum, hum, hum, first off.
You should do one more?
I do do it more!
I am doing it more!
Kawamoji is so great!
This is a wall.
Wall, wall, wall.
Wall.
Wait.
I took a further back?
Not quite, maybe.
Unless?
What if there's like an open path?
Like a top, you know, We fell into one, but what if there's
one up here, too?
You know?
We haven't seen a ceiling sometimes, so...
Yeah, a ceiling path, maybe.
Where am I even?
I'm losing track.
Now I actually feel like I'm looking for a needle in a
haystack, you know?
It would be really sneaky.
It would be.
Especially for a room of this size.
Guys, it would be pretty stinky.
It would be quite stinky if they'd made you do that.
The way the ice melts reminds me of stop motion.
Really?
I don't know how I...
Maybe.
I don't quite see your vision.
But I like it.
I like the vision.
Fun fact.
Wow, with IRL Tesla coils.
Really?
First up.
It does have that frame skip quality.
I guess so.
I really hope it's not a ceiling one.
Like a...
Because I feel like I can't even reach the ceiling here.
Barely.
It's so thick.
It's so thick!
Hold on.
I want to see what you guys are seeing.
To me, I just see it getting sucked up.
Which way was the way to...
That room that we had to get the...
That one out of.
Why are you guys blushing?
They're like contrails.
Kind of like shooting stars.
Right!
Yeah, it's such a cool effect.
It's really nice.
Is there really anything in here?
Yeah, I would feel like I would hear it at some point.
I'm lost.
I think the same guy said path towards first progression.
First progression.
Huh?
Not in here?
Wait, where?
I really want to go to one of those hotel resorts made of
entirely of ice.
Me too, actually.
The first path you took.
The main path.
Wait.
Oh, I'm so confused.
Like, this way?
Not this way?
This one?
Like, the very first path?
Like, in here?
there's many paths that I've taken so saying the first path
doesn't really uh doesn't quite um
wow I just got here wow hello thanks for the super tie I'm
lost
I'm lost I don't know like I want to beat this game but
truly feel like it's gonna be finding needle in a haystack
here like I don't know where I haven't checked yet which I'm
sure there's places right but like but like what where who I
remember this area I think yeah I
should introduce like a little thing that allows it of like
a i need a what's the word
uh metal detector or something but for for artifacts that
should be like something you can buy later on
I'm back here It's around here There's basically a whole
section hidden behind Blue Ice pathway from the main path
This being the main path Blue Ice I have literally not seen
anything though Am I crazy?
I mean yes but
Maybe through here?
I'm stuck I wonder if that gives you a hint Or if it's like
I'm stuck in the map And I can't get out It's probably like
I'm stuck in the map And I can't get out What about this
way?
Oh no
Try it What if it's this way?
Shut up
No way
Up to here The sound!
We can blow this up.
I can't believe I just spent $4.
It's your money, bud.
I can't tell you how to how to spend it.
That's all on you.
Let's see.
Back home?
This is gonna be a bone.
a big old bone.
A big old bone.
A leg.
Oh.
Sorry, I forgot to turn it down.
Yes, yes, yes.
Let's go.
Yeah.
Wow.
The crowds go mild.
Where was that at?
Was that the...
Second song?
No, no, no.
That was a...
Okay, we gotta go back to the first song.
And then we gotta go through...
Wait.
Here?
Yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
And then we go back.
Through.
Here.
Let's see if there's...
Alright, we go back.
this way then.
Uncharted territory maybe?
Wait what is all this going on in here though?
Uh-huh.
Another one!
Yes!
Oh my gosh we made it into here!
We finally were able to go through that one.
Who gave me access to my own bank account?
I think you're going through it, Kevin.
Thanks for the super tag, though.
Hee-hee.
Thanks.
Wait, there's actually a crowbar!
Can I take it?
Place it.
Why can't I use it?
Oh, I tried to use it.
I threw it on the ground.
Place the crowbar here.
Full life!
The achievement was called full life.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sparky, welcome back.
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you.
I'm so glad you're mildly happy for me.
So that means, oh, two?
Just two Arctic Facts left?
Yeah.
I wonder if these are all...
What's the words?
References to things.
Okay.
Where was it?
Because I don't think we got everything.
I vaguely remember.
Okay, let's go to the first stop again.
Full life consequences.
Okay.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Refill.
Unlimited dynamite.
We can buy all the dynamite we could ever want.
100.
And one.
And through here?
And through...
Wait, did I press it?
It wasn't that far.
This away?
Okay.
Because there was one other ledge.
I feel like we didn't go through.
Quite yet.
Oh,
that ain't...
Oops.
I guess they give you the option in case you get here via
without the without the this this thing the throw up there
where was is this the other route route that I was looking
at now I'm confused now I can't remember yeah the hook a
grappling hook yeah yeah Aw, man.
My brain today.
Did not get much sleep last night.
I'm so sorry.
Which way did we go?
I cannot remember.
Let's try both?
I see, I see, I see, I see, I see.
They both lead the same way now, don't they?
Yup.
Okay.
Oh!
Okay, okay, okay.
I guess there nothing was.
Thank you, Kevin.
I'm always going to tell you, though.
Superchat responsibly.
What time did you fall asleep?
Around 2 a.m.
And then I woke up at like 6.
Alright, cool.
guys i need it i i am once again asking for assistance i
there was only one thing that we got there
there was only one
any backseat yeah backseaters if you know this game it's
your time to shine baby otherwise i don't want to say like i
want to beat the game i don't want to be like oh we're not
to it, you know?
But at this point, I feel like I've hit a bit of an empires.
Unless we go back really through the areas that I haven't
checked in a bit.
Like this one.
Oh, I remember this area was the really tough one to get
through.
You guys remember?
This is the one that I was really, like, struggling to get
through, it was, it was, this one was rough.
I was zipping, zooming through this, because I was like, I'm
gonna die in here!
Otherwise, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hmm.
The early Tesla days.
You can tell by just how rough it looks in here.
It was a find anything and everything type of moment.
the hole was very small it was a get through survive,
survive, survive
even now like my oh wait we did not go this way we did not
go this way you guys I remember we found it we found it
look at the size of that hole baby can I make it through
here?
I can't remember actually where this goes.
We might die.
We might lose it all.
The window takes it all!
Did I go through here?
I have no idea.
I think we're about to die.
Never punished.
All right, main hub.
And then there's a couple more that we gotta go back through
there, so...
How did I get there again?
That's the issue.
Dude, what the...
The dragon skull.
Oh!
Wait, did something...
Oh, I thought that opened up there.
Did anything open?
Did it open?
This open?
Over here?
No!
Oh.
Maybe nothing opened.
A chest in the bottom right.
What?
Classic!
Wait, what?
Huh?
I'm get- I'm confused!
What are you guys saying?
We don't die, don't die, don't I?
Was it the second stop?
No, wait.
It was far, wasn't it?
Wait.
Wait, I think we can get back there from the second stop.
They're here.
how did i get over here though oh wait we fell like mega far
never mind we can't go through here i think we gotta go
through the first stop but it's like a far far walk ah okay
okay okay we got this though we got this though
okay but they said chest open vd mega far chest, I also
didn't get much sleep, so my brain also took a while to
click on that one.
I'm not even clicking!
I can't click!
I'm confused by your words!
Oh, it...
Okay.
I think I remember.
I could grapple hook, but we're fine.
We're doing it.
We're just doing it.
I wanted to make sure I was going the right way anyway
first.
So there was also something over here, no?
Yes.
Something over here.
Something here.
Just keep going forward.
We are Where the hecky are we?
Wait, where?
Actually, where are we?
Oh, we're...
Wait.
Oh, it's a circle!
That's so lame.
No!
It was a big old circle!
That's so lame!
Bottom right chest might be... may be empty.
But has a big heart.
Hi!
Hot dog.
Much like booty, a chest is also has another meaning.
Yeah, but by, I'm not flashing anybody, I think.
Is this your subtle way of telling me that you could see
something?
Did I have an accident?
Maybe we should have gone the other way?
We're doing the same thing as before.
floor oh
gosh it's fine if we even if we takes our stuff i don't care
we have nothing nothing of value we have nothing of value
honestly i'm
warm wait this whole area too you guys oh my gosh this whole
area right here we went down we did not we did not go this
way Oh, wow!
There's a whole area here.
I hear something.
Music to my ears, quite literally.
Like, I just actually music to my ears.
Is it up?
How do I get to it?
How do I get to it, though?
Wait, where am I?
There's, like, two paths here.
Wait.
Or I'm lost.
Wait, I'm a bit lost.
Where did I go?
It's like up here.
Oh!
Ice Cube!
How did I get through there?
Wait, how did I get through here?
Oh, like this.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
I'll leave it right there for now.
Because we have this way.
Oh.
Another?
Oh, wait.
It's not hearing this one, is it?
No.
It's not.
There's another one.
Up here?
Treasure chest.
No!
I don't need money.
I'm so rich, please.
I'm rich and low.
Oh, Vombrichen!
Money!
Just money, gosh!
This way.
I think we can still go the other way as well.
Wait?
I...
I hear?
Now what does this open?
okay
thank you
what sucks is we're gonna have to bring both of these back
now
oh and then we have to come all the way back here which is
like so far away it's so far let's see before we do that we
might mega lucky okay and by mega lucky this little area
might bring us to a way that is easier you know okay I think
we got everything over here yeah okay so let's go
down we go
hello Can we get through this?
What?
Oh.
Wait, where is it?
Fight other Kevin.
Who is other Kevin?
Kevin, you're confusing me.
Kevin, I'm not understanding your words.
Oh, through here?
Maybe?
No.
Is that a hole?
Where?
Where does this want me to go?
Kevin is telling you to stop, Kevin.
The kevins are fighting.
Wait, I'm so confused.
What does one step need to do down here?
There's no way to open this guy that I can see.
Unless?
Oh my god, there is!
I'm a dummy dumb.
Wait, this makes it so much easier!
Yeah!
Uh, there.
It unfortunately did not give us any more item, but...
I mean, not that we know of, at least.
This could be a secret passage to the- everything!
To the end game item!
To the item that gets rid of every snow and also brings
every item into your inventory.
That famous item.
That's the path.
Isn't that a bomb?
Will a bomb bring every item to your inventory?
Is that how that works?
I've never used one before, so I'm not an expert.
Ha ha!
I'll turn it down.
Sorry for tracking you into this, Kevin.
Makes me glad my name is Sparky Esquire.
That's true.
That's so true.
Alright, let's go get this last cube.
And then...
I don't know.
It's the second stuff?
No, I'm a silly goose.
It's the first stuff.
Oh, such a silly goose.
It looks complete, but we do not have...
Oh, it's through here, yeah.
That's why I get confused.
Um, we did not get an achievement for it.
I don't think.
I didn't hear one.
Oh, nice.
We're so close, you guys to finishing this.
For real.
Okay, good.
I have time.
Let's see.
Yeah, we're missing a piece of the mammoth and we're missing
one artifact.
Thank you, Kevin, for the super chat.
That's my name.
Don't wear it out.
Eggie!
Oh, dragon egg.
Dragon egg.
Game of thorns.
Find the dragon egg.
There's nothing really open at all.
Nothing?
Nothing opens?
Nothing to check out?
No?
Okay.
Well, we got all the artifacts!
Yippee!
And now there is one last mammoth.
Maybe?
One last?
Or two?
Looks like one probably in the middle.
Yele!
Good much love!
Thank you, Arso!
Thank you so much for the super chat.
Just gotta complete it, yeah.
Unless there's tail.
I don't think so.
I think that's, that looks like enough of a tailbone.
Yeah, that definitely looks like enough.
I like that the second rib cage is not connected.
Wait!
hmm
just leaves one thing I think so, just one more now I'm
actually like okay maybe somewhere in the second stop I
think the door opened near that egg I don't think so we went
in here it was very chilly there was just one thing unless
there's one more We'll check.
I don't think so, though.
Sometimes there's, like, phantom items.
You see it?
It gets me.
Hi, Minty, how are you doing today?
I'm doing amazing, Matthew.
How are you?
You're a free member.
Okay.
I don't think it I think it don't it doesn't work that way I
think I think if you are gifted a membership you actually
don't have to unsubscribe it just does it for you since it
was a gift great that's great secret hatch in the secret
area what what does that mean
myth run i need you to be more specific secret hatch in the
what
no there's a secret area
do you have the thing where you can gift free monthly
members as the channel owner uh i don't know i've never
tried I can super chat myself show support for mint phantom
that's me notice when I try something new with desserts or
coffees I've been reaching for mint flavored stuff the brain
rot is real the brain rot is real one thing though one thing
though is I saw this other this new feature that I guess
YouTube is trying to put out and it's like I guess for for
regular videos You can put out a quiz.
I don't even know what that means.
They were like, do you want to add a quiz to your video?
I was like, yeah, I'm going to be like, when's my birthday?
I'm going to be like, where is the final?
We got that one.
There was another one, no, that I remember it being behind a
wall and I couldn't get it.
I don't know where that was.
I'm gonna look it up.
I don't care anymore.
I'm games faxing this game.
Game fax.
You guys are too slow.
Sorry.
Game fax.
If you were like, I'm the best backseater here.
It's your favorite flavor.
They wish us.
I love mint too.
I love mint chocolate.
wait okay hold on I actually wrote game facts meltopia
mammoth pieces what's wrong with a a tips tools and mammoth
guide all right help me out game help me out it's it's it's
a guide wait what secrets are hidden underground oh okay no
I need I I need you to be more specific.
Find, no, they're not telling me exactly where it is.
What happens if we fail the quiz?
Do we have to start over again watching VODs from a year
ago?
No, then you probably won't watch recent VODs, right?
That'd be so sad.
This Meltopia Steam post just says, Lost!
Lust!
It's very dark to see things.
The flashlight is not powerful enough.
I've unlocked the second stop and got the shovel.
I've tried to find all the dirt piles and dig down, but
ultimately I end up going through platforming.
I like this game, but it needs some tweaks.
Oh my gosh.
No one is telling me exactly where I need to go.
I have no idea.
I am lost as well.
The TV show.
Can we look at the mammoth, please?
We're checking?
Oh, of course.
Are you guys actually checking?
You're so sweet.
It looks like...
Whatever this piece is.
This map is odd.
Dave does need some tweaking.
I'll give it, I will say that.
Like, you know, a map would be great.
Like, a way to place markers and stuff.
But overall, I think the premise of it is really great.
And, like, the way the you soak up the...
I was going to say suck up the...
You melt the snow is very satisfying.
YouTube quiz Is Mito cute?
A, yes, B, yes, C, yes, D, yes.
Yes, D, yes, C, yes, B, yes.
Yes, yes.
Oh, I'm Folly.
Now what was the correct answer, guys?
I also would appreciate some little lore bits, right?
upgrade is still a chore though so true that was that was
the roughest part of the game even though i'm lost right now
the tesla pre-upgrade was a slog that one was pretty bad
i fear i feel like i've actually gotten everything now
though that scares me
i'll put our best guess on the densitude discord but the map
available is not great Then set to Discord.
There it is.
No, that's not it.
Where's the... Oh, no.
There it is.
Is it under Minto Live?
What is this map?
Okay.
Show the map?
You could join Densetsu Discord, though.
And then you will see.
I'm watching you guys right now.
This map is in Russian.
I understand second stop.
I think I can maybe figure it out.
Maybe.
maybe
let's go to the second second stop
okay second stop oh there we go okay oh rigid there we go uh
where am I anyway is there a oh okay we gotta go up here I
was there a Kevin Wolf I don't think there was a Kevin war.
I think you made that up in your head, Kevin.
No, I should have left.
Turn left at yabloko baloko.
Yabloko baloko.
All right.
So I'm guessing this is...
Hold on.
I'm guessing this one is this top one right here.
Okay.
Sure.
Let's do it.
To be fair?
I...
I feel like this would be the place that I haven't explored
the most.
You know what I mean?
Maybe.
I wonder if there's anything down here.
Please, let me help!
Wait!
You're late!
There we go.
Wait, did I go?
Did I go the wrong way?
Ah!
I went the wrong way.
Wait.
Hoppies!
It's okay, we can run to the next area.
It's right over here.
Ooh, it's chilly.
It's chilly.
Alright.
Hoppies, hoppies, hoppies, hoppies.
I don't think there was...
Yeah, this, okay.
Just making sure it was a...
The sound is repeating itself.
He didn't...
The devs did not get a long enough of a blistery winter
Wonderland sound.
Okay.
I think the piece you're missing is in the ruins.
What's the ruins?
Three second breeze.
Okay.
We're so close you guys.
I believe I believe I believe I believe I believe
This is the ruins right Unless it's like in here
But then I think we would have hurt wait a second.
Did I go this way?
Yeah, must have right?
Yeah, yeah, we went because we went to down.
Yeah, yeah.
How?
This is also!
How do I get to here?
I'm quivering with anticipation.
Poor Dickie.
I tried to find this one.
Or rather...
I thought I had found it.
So it must be there, right?
It has to there.
Okay.
The only place left intact.
Exactly.
Okay.
Hmm.
The music is so like polite all of a sudden.
Maybe there's just a way that I didn't find over here or
something.
Yeah, because we dug here.
Look at the remnants of the pudding.
Oh, no, the more remnants of the pudding.
Do I go down, maybe?
No.
Then we did this pudding.
And that's when I thought I found all the pudding.
But I hadn't, clearly.
This is a red bit.
And then we parkored.
And the...
there's more snow down what no that's this is not a snow you
can take care of or whatever huh it's up here at the top
it's but I've already been here
unless I actually missed it which is entirely possible who
who huh Is this like normal snow?
No.
Then I...
Grab?
You can never get all the pudding out of your cup.
No, I can't.
And then I got this one.
Hmm.
No.
I guess...
I guess I really did go through it.
wow that's a really generous period i didn't think it was
that much time
i do not know i do not know
it's not a period i'm surprised you haven't noticed oh well
i mean i don't die because i'm good i'm good at the game i
don't die maybe because of the suit I don't know.
I think...
I think I...
Froggy, they get so much with the five get the...
I don't want to say I give up, but...
I really don't know anywhere else to go, anywhere else to
do.
I feel like I've hit up everything at this point.
What
if I go down here?
Oh,
never mind.
Never mind.
I was so like, oh my gosh, I found it.
I found the secret.
I was so sure that I had found the secret.
Are we lost, boss?
We are.
We're super lost.
We...
I think this is the end of the road for us, guys.
Lost!
I'm the one that...
I have a confession.
I'm the one that posted that...
I'm the one that posted...
That Steam posted.
The door usable or for show?
What, this one over here?
Oh, for sure.
I don't think there's been a single door we've been able to
actually open.
Like, with our hands.
Explodable?
We could try it.
Why not?
What else do we have to lose?
Fire in the...
after your first stream i think the last one is through
another path in the room where you found the shovel near the
dirt path you can't dig up i don't
quite want to go on a wild goose chase would solid snake or
big boys give up maybe oh wait um probably going this way
would be easier
I'm looking at the map again.
It just passed it.
What?
Try, I'm stuck.
I'm stuck!
Oh.
Wait, where did this put me?
Oh, okay.
Wait.
Okay, not that far.
This is...
Okay.
I'm trying to follow the map.
But I'm also...
This is where you get the suit.
Okay, so basically they say from here you get the suit.
and you can go this way and then there's apparently a path
to your right
somewhere I passed it or is it on my left it's very dark is
it this?
what?
glow sticks like here?
like how close how close are we talking to this entrance
area you know because nothing here is very dark at all
unless it's this oh
i'm gonna change my my stream to how to find every artifact
in the game.
Tutorial style.
That is so terrible.
This is all, this is, that's the worst.
That's actually the worst.
I bet nothing, I bet we're gonna get nothing out of this.
If we do, I'm gonna be so happy.
Lost.
Take the W big GM.
We're taking it, we're taking it.
What is happening?
all of those just to be thrown in the furnace.
I got to see him for two seconds.
Are we heating the Earth?
What is happening?
You've contributed to achieving a universal human goal,
shifting Earth's orbit closer to the sun.
Now we're one step closer to solving the problem of a new
ice age.
The music all overlapping.
Yeah!
Mito, are we the baddies?
No, we saved!
We saved the world, right?
We're stopping the second Ice Age!
We put...
That...
Oh, it's...
Orbital engine launch of a planetary orbital engine.
He's all burnt now.
No!
My...
My mammoth skull!
So do these never open up over here?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
they never do.
That's it.
That's it, baby.
Rest in Glitch Race.
Thank you so much for the five gifted.
We cooked it.
Now we're gonna cook ourselves.
Get in there.
Fight fire with fire.
Yahoo!
Bros.
cooked.
We did it.
Good job.
Thank you so much fossil fuels.
Thanks for the comfy slop affectionate stream.
I funded the card.
Thank you, Meryl.
That was pretty stupid.
Yeah, the game definitely needs quality of life
improvements, but I think I, overall, I enjoyed the game.
Just a few things that could have been, you know, that could
have been, that can be improved upon.
Easy Toys!
Thank you so much for the 10 gifted!
Thank you.
Following Minto into the sun.
I don't think we're going to the sun.
I think we're moving closer to the sun.
We did it, Patrick.
We saved the city!
There's also a DLC.
The Meltopia Frozen Expedition Supporter Pack.
I think, though, I think I remember seeing that it was
like...
what's the word
skins and stuff no thank you map and waypoints would be
perfect I agree I agree it's just cosmetic yeah it seems
like okay just cosmetic I mean I do hope that they expand on
the game though and add some quality of life things but I
think I think the game was satisfying enough for me to have
enjoyed it and i hope you guys enjoyed it too and we saved
the earth oh well thank you thank you very much you you yeah
this is fun though thank you for the stream good job
sticking with it and thank you for your contribution to
global warming now we can melt in the summer
Hope you have a great time with everything tonight and get
lots of sleep after.
Darko, thank you so much for the peek.
Thank you.
Thank you so, so much.
I really, really appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Grappling hook.
The grappling hook was pretty fun.
And it's, like, OP.
I do wish that, like, we could use it, like, kind of more
Spider-Man-ish.
I want to be...
I want to be Aaron Yeager up here.
I don't want to be, you know...
Like I'm constantly pressing Q, but...
Save your game.
So true.
Yay, but thank you.
I'm gonna go get ready for the convention?
Oh, I got going on.
I was kind of looking forward to freezing.
Let's go freeze.
Do you actually not die?
That's so funny.
Imagine once you get the suit, you don't die.
Fake me!
Thank you so much for the pain!
Thank you.
Let's go to a really freezy, breezy area.
Thanks for the stream.
I didn't win the meet and greet.
No!
Cece!
My yesterday's panel was so fun.
See you at the concert later today.
See you!
Cece, no!
...
That's the only words I know to the song.
It's also the only part I know of the song.
It just loops inside my head.
I don't know how to stop it.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow,
meow.
That was such a team effort.
I wouldn't have been able to find that last piece without
you guys' help.
So thank you.
That one was a real tough one.
That was a...
So it doesn't feel like it should have been such a stinker,
but it was.
Why am I not losing...
Oh, suddenly when I start running, look how fast my thing
goes down.
Oh, there's still buddy to be grabbed in here.
Okay.
Maybe if I run down here.
Yeah, let's freeze to death.
We're gonna freeze to death.
In the heat of the summer, we're gonna freeze to death
together.
Isn't that so cool and romantic?
Like listening to Minecraft finals in your kitchen.
La la la la.
We're gonna freeze in the summer.
Three snowflakes of freeze.
It's a real wind chill.
La la la la la la la la.
Why does it feel like suddenly, before I was, like,
stressing?
Now all of a sudden I'm like...
Oh, is it because we heated up the world, you think?
Have a
good time, Joan, and I will see you.
When I...
When I see you next!
Bye-bye!